[Music]
you jakesully
I'd like to talk to you about fresh
start on a new world you'd be making a
difference
[Music]
forgive me marine for the hardship I
told myself I can pass any test of
making past
was a single thing worth fighting for
ladies and gentlemen
you're not in Kansas anymore you're on
Pandora
you should see your faces
there beyond that fence we have an
indigenous population called the Navi
this is why we're here because this
little gray rock sells for twenty
million a kilo their village happens to
be resting on the richest deposit and
they need to relocate you're supposed to
be finding a diplomatic solution
the concept is to drive these remotely
controlled bodies called avatars they
grown from human DNA mixed with DNA of
the natives marine did inhabit our body
I some won't mix you get me what I need
I'll see to it you get your legs bent
your real legs yes sir looks like you
this is your avatar
let your mind go blank
shouldn't be heard for you
[Music]
Jake makes real simple
I want you to learn from the inside I
want you to gain their trust
[Music]
you should not be here
[Music]
whoo this is your fault I need your help
[Music]
outstanding
haven't gotten lost in the woods have
you you forget what team you're playing
for strong prey on the weak you nobody
doesn't think you've got one hour we
knew this would happen
pretty changed it gets crazy here before
Rich's taking over he's rolling
I guess we better stop here
[Music]
they've sent us a message that they can
take whatever they want but we will send
them a message
there's our left
[Music]
[Music]
you